sehr geehrte damen und herren liebe
gäste ich begrüße sie recht herzlich zur
pressekonferenz der partei die linke
heute mit der parteivorsitzenden
susanne ähnlich wenn sie die zu den
aktuellen entwicklungen im
bundestagswahl zu ihnen sprechen wird
bitteschön sonntag auch von mir
vielleicht zu einer erst seit gestern
abend dem 3l was wahrscheinlich viele
hier im raum gesehen haben und auch
darüber hinaus liegen jahren die
politischen karten im land offen
zumindest ein stückchen weit werden
gestern drei kandidatinnen r nehmen
können die nicht darüber gesprochen
haben dass es einen deutlichen
richtungswechsel in diesem land geben
muss die nicht darüber reden konnten wie
sie den osten entwickeln wollen und
vieles mehr drei westdeutsche die über
den osten reden und sagen können sie
haben ja schon mal alles gegessen oder
sie haben in potsdam beziehungsweise
brandenburg ihren wohnsitz so ein
bisschen für mich mit meiner
ostdeutschen biografie natürlich etwas
schwierig das als ost erfahrung zu
anzuerkennen aus dem einfachen grund
potsdam ist nicht der osten potsdam es
hat mit das höchste pro-kopf-einkommen
überhaupt und
potsdam
[Musik]
hat viele millionäre und ist durchaus
eine stadt in der sich gut leben lässt
das stimmt aber nicht osten ist und ost
erfahrung heißt eben auch was dann nicht
gesagt worden ist nämlich dass der osten
durchaus nach wie vor unsere hilfe auch
aus der bundespolitik braucht um
tatsächlich sich weiterzuentwickeln
da geht es darum stichwort mindestlohn
ein mindestlohn von 13 euro würde im
osten bedeuten dass über 40 prozent der
arbeitnehmerinnen mehr gehalt bekommen
wir haben die frage der demografischen
entwicklung in den ostdeutschen
bundesländern deutlicher als in den
westdeutschen bundesländern
da was wiederum die frage der fachkräfte
auch in pflege in bildungsberufen und
uns ausmacht
gleichzeitig auch eine durchaus sehr
froh und junge kultur auch aus dem osten
selbst groß zu werden die städte zu
entwickeln den ländlichen raum zu
entwickeln aber die frage des ostens war
durchaus sehr dünn beantwortet
vielleicht zum thema regierungsfähigkeit
regierungsfähigkeit da sprechen drei
parteien über regierungsfähigkeit die
hartz 4 1 geführt haben die den
afghanistan einsatz
zumindest rot grün auf den weg gebracht
haben da reden parteien miteinander die
sich für regierungsfähig halten obwohl
sie auch etwas zugelassen haben wir die
cdu den masken die
während der korona zeit das heißt dass
ich ihre eigenen abgeordneten auch daran
bereichern dass eine regierungspartei
ihn ermöglicht da auch die masken dienst
einzufädeln
insofern würde ich mal sagen über
regierungsfähigkeit reden wir anders
auch mit blick auf afghanistan jetzt das
einzige was die drei geschafft haben ist
ein verbales wettrüsten nach diesem
afghanistan desaster zuallererst darüber
reden dass man das 2% ziele der nato
einheit musste dass man die bundeswehr
aufrüsten muss aber nicht darüber wie
man aus einer interventionspolitik
herauskommt wie man zu einer friedlichen
außen und sicherheitspolitik kommt wie
man entwicklungszusammenarbeit stärkt
auch in zusammenarbeit mit den vereinten
nationen dass es findet schon ziemlich
abgefahren dass sich dass diese bei drei
parteien leisten mal davon abgesehen
dass man sich jetzt fragen muss ob es
demnächst mit einem wehrpflicht in
diesem bundesland in dieser
bundesrepublik geben wird ob es
bewaffnete drohnen auch wenn die
bundeswehr geben wird
all das sind fragen die gestern offen
geblieben sind aber es ist nicht das
zeichen für entspannung politik
für das aufhören mit konfrontation auch
in richtung russland china gesetzt
wurden sondern eher das gegenteil und
das besorgt mich doch schon sehr
es
bedeutet eben auch regierungsfähigkeit
zu verstehen das nicht bekenntnis
politik machen sollen dass menschen
politik machen dass wir politik für
menschen machen das bedeutet man muss
schon sagen dass die verteilungsfrage
die eigentumsfrage die entscheidende
frage dafür sein wird welche partei
welche konzepte umsetzen kann und da
sind wir in einer richtung
auseinandersetzung in konstellationen
bedeutet dass auf der einen seite
natürlich die union und die fdp direkt
die die reichen immer reicher machen
wollen auf der anderen seite sind das
natürlich die progressiven parteien spd
grüne als auch linke die dort nicht
sagen dass sie von den dingen die
vermögend sind natürlich auch erwarten
dass sie sich gesellschaftlich begleiten
wir sagen vermögenssteuer wir sagen
vermögensabgabe damit wir auch eine
gesellschaftliche spaltung
zurückweisen können mit einem sozialen
fundament mit einem wirksamen
klimawandel oder mit einem wirksamen
kampf gegen den klimawandel und das
alles bedeutet dass man an eine andere
geld und vermögens politik in diesem
land machen muss das schließt die cdu
und die fdp aus deswegen ist mir nicht
erklärlich wie grüne als auch spd ihre
projekte mit beiden parteien umsetzen
wollen insofern auch von meiner seite
das unverständnis
[Musik]
warum spd und grüne sich jetzt
verschanzen um zu sehen welche chancen
mehr als drei abend nichts haben
tatsächlich dieses land zum positiven zu
verändern in den nächsten zehn bis 15
jahren und
soziale spaltung in diesem land zu
überwinden so weit vielleicht erst mal
von mir
ja ich finde jetzt die beiden parteien
die diesen nato-einsatz mit unterstützt
haben bei beginn des nato einsatzes in
afghanistan vor 20 jahren sie müssen
sich erstmal jetzt den kopf machen wie
sie ihre eigene außen und
sicherheitspolitik tatsächlich neu
orientieren wollen es hat sich gezeigt
dass konfrontation und intervention
eingriffe beziehungsweise politik dann
nicht zum erfolg geführt haben und
insofern würde ich sagen bekenntnisse
kann jeder einfordern ob bekenntnisse
tatsächlich
[Musik]
brauchbar sind in der politik ist die
nächste frage und ganz nebenbei
sagen wir ja wir wollen
statt einer nato ein kooperatives
sicherheitsbündnis auch mit russland
einfach um die welt sicherer zu machen
und
ich finde im mittelpunkt steht für eine
nächste konditionen frieden und
sicherheitspolitik als einheit zu denken
und nicht weiter in konfrontationen
naja ein klares bekenntnis zur leitung
würde heute bedeuten ein kriegsbündnis
tatsächlich die stimme zu geben dass wir
als linke auch sagen wir wollen dass
zwei prozent ziel vom bibb was die nato
einfordert nicht weil es bedeutet bei
sozialen leistungen zu sparen im
gesundheitssektor zu sparen das ist auch
der fall ist eine auch nicht die haltung
von annalena baerbock die da sagt naja
man kann das nicht an einem 2 prozent
ausmachen wenn der bundeshaushalt
bekommt die bundeswehr und den
verteidigungshaushalt natürlich dann
weniger geld deswegen bräuchte man eine
feste summe ich kenne das alles nicht
unser auftrag in der bundesrepublik ist
für abrüstung zu sorgen ist es dafür zu
sorgen dass natürlich die bundeswehr bei
dem gerät was sie hat auch vernünftiges
und qualitatives gerät hat aber nicht
dass sie im ausland tatsächlich auch
kriege unterstützen und interventionen
und beginnen könnte man zum beispiel mit
einem
waffenexport stoppt man könnte sofort
als bundesrepublik als rot und grün den
atomwaffen verbots vertrag
unterschreiben dass wir ein klares
zeichen auch global zu sagen wir wollen
eine friedliche außenpolitik
also
unser wille ist da
sehr eindeutig wir haben eine aufgabe in
diesem land und wir sind das soziale
gewissen in diesem land und das bedeutet
dass unsere auftrag als partei die linke
ist alle hebel in bewegung zu setzen
damit niemand mehr an sein muss damit
allen sozial abgesichert sind damit wir
es schaffen den klimawandel auch
durchaus sehr realistisch und sehr
knapp zu begegnen und wir sind
diejenigen die natürlich die
eigentumsfrage die vermögens- frage
damit in den mittelpunkt rücken weil es
ohne ein deutliches besteuern auf
derjenigen die genug vermögen haben dass
das möglich ist sprich die reichen auch
nicht möglich sein wird diese
gesellschaft weiterzuentwickeln
und wir sind natürlich auch der
auffassung dass wir ein staat eine
verantwortung haben dass wir kredite
aufnehmen müssen dass wir die kredite
refinanzieren im mit dem geld was wir
uns von denjenigen die es geht haben
auch zurückholen tatsächlich garantieren
dass der sozialstaat weiter bestehen
bleibt um weil wir als einzige dieser
auftrag erfüllen ist es für uns sage ich
mal klar wie kloßbrühe dass wir zwei
einer regierung sein wollen sofern das
arithmetisch passt
naja wir beide verhandeln ja hier nicht
sondern das macht man ja dann am tisch
und nicht über die presse insofern kann
ich ihnen aber nur sagen dass alle
vereinen werden müssen alle kompromisse
eingehen müssen und nicht nur den link
unser ziel ist es das wird tatsächlich
die soziale frage in den mittelpunkt
stellen wie gestaltet man hat es hier
aus wie macht man arbeitslosengeld wie
gelingt es uns das niemand mehr in ein
loch fallen muss in krisen die uns
gesellschaftlicher ein könnte das hat ja
corona aufgezeigt
[Musik]
herzlichen dank ich sie keine weiteren
fragen zu diesem zeitpunkt seien aber
natürlich selbstverständlich
wenn die verlängerung der epidemische
anlage hatte unsere bundestagsfraktion
auch in der vergangenen woche im
bundestag mit entschieden im sinne von
wir sind nicht für die verlängerung der
epidemischen lage das hat was mit
demokratischen prozessen und ähnlichem
zu tun das zweite aus unserer sicht wäre
es von vorteil 3g beizubehalten um nicht
auf zweig zu gehen das hat was mit
ausgrenzung bei 2g von menschen zu tun
die sich nicht impfen lassen können
schwangere zum beispiel
und 3g wäre einfach eine größere
sicherheit auf eine gesellschaft
tatsächlich noch mehr in den griff zu
bekommen und möglicherweise zu
überwinden
ja dann noch mal vielen dank für ihr
interesse ich wünsche ihnen noch eine
schöne woche und freue mich wenn wir sie
in der nächsten woche an dieser stelle
wieder begrüßen können dankeschön